hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich euch jedes gerät und ich
habe heute zwei gäste hier mehr dazu
geholt wir machen heute nach langer zeit
mal wieder was ganz anderes was sie hier
gar nicht mehr so gewohnt seid aber ich
hatte da echt bock drauf und deswegen
dachte ich mir mache ich das einfach mal
auch das turnier dabei ist finde ich
super wir fangen erst mal mit der dame
an marie ist heute dabei viele fragen
sich jetzt sicherlich helfen da der sind
wir dachten uns einfach dass es
eigentlich mal ganz lustig ist und die
verstehen uns oft ob deswegen ist marie
heute am start und jakob sehr sehr guter
freund kommen hier wo bist du da kann
man ja an dieser stelle sagen oder haben
ja da hast du kannst ja mal sagen was du
schon so gemacht hast damit die leute
auch wissen das ja nicht dass die
erwartung später zu groß sind an einer
geber nicht ich weiß dass du gekommen
dann so kannst du jetzt auch mal raus
und ja meine eltern arbeiten elterlichen
betrieb arbeitet an dem neben weiter mit
und hamburg gearbeitet in baden-baden
und also unterm strich habe auch schon
oft gegessen und so ist wirklich ein top
koch deswegen ist die qualität heute
schon mal gesichert weil ich kann es ja
noch sogar ja ich erkläre ich mal was
wir vorhaben das ganze ist gesponsert
von hello fresh die haben uns ganz ganz
viel essen zur verfügung gestellt die im
hintergrund kann man das wunderbar sind
da ist echt jede menge bei und euch
beiden erkläre ich jetzt mal die
challenge und zwar ich weiß was wir
kochen ihr beiden ist es nicht okay also
wir werden gleich alle dasselbe gericht
kochen beziehungsweise mit denselben
zutaten ich kenne das rezept ihr könnt
nicht alle können freestyle machen die
ihr denkt so muss ich bin nicht mehr
mitgezählt
ja also ich denke es wird lustig ich
würde sagen wir lieber gar nicht lange
denn dank ein hello fresh das ist echt
cool da kann man jede menge rezepte
auswählen egal ob es legal ist
vegetarisch mit fleisch ihr könnt eure
gerichte immer anpassen ich zeige euch
hier auch direkt mein gutscheincode
damit bekommt ihr auf jeden fall bis zu
90 euro rabatt auf die ersten vier
bestellungen hierbei hätten verstehe
dich deswegen check das gerne ab und wir
schauen jetzt mal was da in den schön
boxen drin ist man muss auch sagen wir
haben jetzt ganz viele gerichte bekommt
für die ganze woche wir haben jetzt in
alle boxen einmal reingeschaut ist das
schwert saniererin ich glaub der lachs
aus alaska überall sind dieselben
rezeptoren drin und die packen wir jetzt
mal gemeinsam aus das hier ist das
rezept das geht nur mich was an was man
auch wir haben ja einmal die
wunderschönen breyer spannend schönen 3
wir wollen ja auch immer für drei leute
eigentlich und probieren dann haben wir
hier alles sehr nachhaltig natürlich
produziert machen wir gleich mal in ruhe
auf und haben
salate tomaten kartoffeln was sagst du
ja immer bürger nicht schlecht dann
haben wir hier die nummer 15 und die
nummer 30 es ist natürlich wichtig wie
die auch die man zu kennen fürs rezept
was ihr aber nicht kennen darum geht es
heute das ist die nummer 15 das müsste
alles gekennzeichnet sein wir haben wir
noch die nummer 30 auch sehr sehr lecker
kann ich euch mal sagen bis im chip
seelachs burger mit grünem salat und
rinderfilet spitzen mit chemie jury auf
salat kannst du das kleine wer möchte
anfangen marie fängt an hier sind die
produkte drin die gekühlt werden alles
natürlich recyclebar und nachhaltig hier
sind auch kühl pads drin damit das nicht
schlecht wird also hier ist zum beispiel
auch der seelachs drin aber hier haben
wir das rinderhack sagt
fleischzubereitung aus rind- und
schweinefleisch muss man nicht verwenden
ihr seid ganz frei aber klicks mal
hierzu das gehört nicht zu den rezepten
hier irgendwie meint ihr müsst davon
noch irgendwas reintun dann könnt ihr
gerne auch mal zwischendurch hier
reinschauen da habe ich nichts gegen
eigentlich und ich würde sagen heute ich
bin gespannt ich habe mich großen hunger
marie gibt dir mühe jetzt obwohl leute
marie beginnt dann schau dir mal an was
soziales
gewürz das gar nicht verwenden gar nicht
wir respektieren war aber dann schauen
wir was ist also hier in der in der tüte
das verrät ja einiges oder hat ja dann
ist so eine tomatensoße passierte
tomaten
noch mehr boden ganz viele bogen
fiesta gewürzmischung
und habe ich hier so ok du kannst gerne
auch mal eben hier in der tüte schauen
vielleicht ist da ja noch was dabei
völlig ein paar lebensmittel müssen ja
immer gekühlt sein also hier ist ja
schon gar kein käse wein was wird dass
gleich
jemand
weiß ich jetzt nicht hier
auch was geschmack ist ein anderes
gericht er so hier sind zum beispiel
genau das gehört jetzt nicht dazu das
kann man heute abend vielleicht mal
testen oder so sauber ich uns dann mal
aber das war es glaube ich wenn du da
noch was findest dann nimmt das wird
noch irgendwas nehmen davon obwohl du
darfst nicht verraten zurück ok marie
dann macht das kochen wir sind gespannt
ich hab nämlich ganz großen da ist halt
viel gemüse bei von den anderen
lieferungen ich habe nichts dagegen wenn
sie das nimmt uwe schwenker ein bisschen
haben wir
sowieso der teilweise noch zwölf werden
aber
eigentlich gut machen oder also wenn ich
die nachbarn eigene rezept macht kann es
ja eine pizza damit machen oder einen
danken leute ich hatte ganz vergessen
dass diese chili habe liebe scharfes
essen deswegen riskiere ich jetzt jetzt
die chillida noch ein bisschen rein zu
machen ganz ganz ganz wenig hätte ich
doch jakob jetzt da könnt ihr nur sagen
ob ich übertreibe und ob das zu schaffen
bei mir ist auch nicht normal ich
vertrag würde ich selber schärfer es
kann nicht ob das überhaupt irgendetwas
bewirkt leute weil das ist echt nicht
viel aber besser zu wenig als zu viel
das problem ist halt dass es noch sehr
sehr flüssig ist deswegen wissen und ich
genau wie ich das zu halten bringen
sollten bleibt nach hält aber jetzt
kommen erst mal da kommt nämlich auch
noch ein bisschen käse draufstehe das
jetzt einmal um damit das auch von
beiden seiten schönes und da kommt jetzt
überall käse drauf damit das schön
schmelzkäse fast immer gut ich mache ich
das jetzt mit dem salat oder nicht
müssen wir das auch schön anrichten ja
da okay leute ich mache jetzt ganz wenig
salat noch dazu und das legen wir noch
leichter rein einfach damit es besser
hält alles und salat ist eigentlich das
einzige was ich richtig gut kann und
nudeln
das liegt auch schon mal gut aus die
überlege gerade wieder um ich es am
besten mache ob ich es wie eine pizza
mache und das darauf schmiere ich glaube
ich mache das so rum das erste salat so
ein bisschen drauf kommt weil glaube
dann hätte das tatsächlich alles besser
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das geht
oder ist zu hart er ist wirklich zu hart
jetzt nicht zu hoch sie total süß aus
oder sieht sie das und die hauptsache
ist doch dass ist schmeckt es ist der
salat so ja was auch wieder da marie hat
hier völlig gezaubert wird meinte ja ist
doch lecker oder mehr probieren einfach
hier jetzt einfach mal hier
es war gar keine so wenn du jetzt mal
was so siehts uhr
so jetzt kommen
[Musik]
in dem restaurant auch mal für mal eben
auf die hand und ist ja auch
vegetarische gute produkte ich glaube
schon
ein
bisschen flüssig so also es schmeckt
auch so gut gemacht hätte natürlich
besser angepasst so dass ich so geklappt
hat aber trotzdem alles gut ist finster
kaufen danke ihr könnt mich alle
catering buchen lassen ja ich bin halt
der deutsche web master in deutschland
am liebsten eigentlich gar nicht auch
eher klassisch ich brauche jetzt nicht
im web sind nicht mein tägliches brot
würde ich sagen das hast du denn was du
jeden tag source das was die leute halt
so essen passt da wieso ist oder kinder
viele gibt es auch er einmal
also das ist ja was für dich oder eine
fiche ich liebe fisch zum beispiel
also hier sind wir gleich erst wahr
machen salat das jetzt primaten
barbecues wurde jetzt da sitzt du
bestimmst gar kein gewürzt ja lustig und
wohnt wo das war's auch schon und gleich
ruft nissan nehmen wir mal dort 60
das ist eine größte fahne oder
das ist steinzeit wir haben noch was
eigentlich schüssel
achja
hartkäse italienischer das brauchen wir
glaube ich nie gute milch citroen racing
können wir eigentlich fast für den salat
zu marinieren so ein bisschen nehmen
schmandt ja die nämlich käsemix
500 darüber streichen naturjoghurt und
das war's schon oder noch mal den
seelachs machen wir auch noch drauf die
chaperone niveau kommt die heilig und wo
kommen die her
also ja ich würde schon mit verwenden
gegeben im folgejahr der fahne muss ja
erst mal heiß werden muss dass fleischer
ordentlich angeraten
wird es mir gleich mal ein bisschen habe
ich schon noch was drauf machen dann
hast du ein bisschen öl zum anbraten
dann so möglich jetzt nicht das beste
das gesündeste aber es erfüllt seinen
zweck würde ich mal sagen was sie kochen
lassen die so was
wir hier machen wir
das gleiche längst oder was ist hier mit
den tomaten wenn ihr auch verwendet
werden machen wir hier
wirklich klein und mit zerstückelten
helau auf jetzt da jetzt machen wir mal
später dran paprika knoblauch moment
sind sie dem er selbst die folgen das
ist schon sehr überzeugend was ich jetzt
höre ja ich hab ja auch ein ich tolle
produkte hiervon helfrich also da kann
ja eigentlich nichts schief gehen oder
hätte meine schützen
meinte
falter mit dem stumpfen
manchmal so ein bisschen raus also die
kerne sind glaube ich antreten das ist
gar nicht so scharf dass sind alter
das war bestimmt schärfer ist der motor
während weil
obwohl
[Musik]
wir mal dran diesmal hier glaube ich
mache das jetzt seit ein bisschen haben
wir nämlich
vermitteln hier die peperoni rein damit
sie vielleicht ein bisschen schärfe gibt
überladen saubermachen jetzt hat das
schöne bräunung wenn man das gleich ein
bisschen ablöschen mit dem tomaten
zurück dass er drin ist später den wohn
auffüllen und dann auf die abwehr hat
relativ viel stärke und dann wird das
alles so ein bisschen gebunden
[Musik]
über solche machen 1
2380 apple gleich haben wir also das
sieht schon richtig gut aus was für
zaubers ich bin wirklich gespannt ich
glaube dass wir richtig lecker und ich
kann mir auch schon 1 verwahrten du bist
verdammt
echt
immer noch ein bisschen was von der
neuen gewürzmischung ran kann man ja
nichts falsch machen würde ich sagen war
das für dich so von vornherein klar dass
das wird sagt ist oder hat man
wahrscheinlich sagen ja ich war also ich
habe einfach die sachen gesehen die so
drin waren und irgendwie
konnte man nichts anderes machen also
marie hat sich da was einfallen lassen
das einzige was ich anders gemacht hätte
ich hätte das fleisch noch deutlich
kleiner gemacht weißt du dass man das
einfach so ja ja ok aber es wird schon
noch ne du bist ja man kann ja nie
auslernen
sollte ich habe mir zu und ich muss
jetzt zu essen theoretisch eigentlich
muss sich am ende auch mit kochen aber
das ist schon genau das rezept schaue
ich mal sagen jetzt machen wir den salat
um bisschen mit der buttermilch zitronen
dressing alles kann man etwas zu lassen
wenn er so ein bisschen reduziert ist
gar nicht gut
ich muss halt gucken es ist ja nicht zu
toppen ist
eigentlich ein solches tuch oder so
drauflegen wollen kann das ding so kann
man sich ja später zum tippen nehmen
oder na gut daran das ding jetzt oder
erst
mal hier mal was genau würde ich jetzt
will ich das ding hier denn auch
wenn wir das jetzt gleich rollen nur so
kann ist offen hier auf der seite
ziemlich macht frische durch den schwanz
und ein bisschen rausgucken wird will
hier
[Musik]
viel hilft viel das hier so
so oder so
[Musik]
alex marie muss ja auch noch mal ran
holen oder so jetzt probiere ich mal
hier was du auch das was kann
man gegen japan hat auch das rezept
eigentlich genau nach gemacht wurde noch
mal probieren
sie wird mit also ich finde das schmeckt
wirklich ausgezeichnet lag also ich
hatte jetzt nicht gedacht dass man
daraus so das leckere draußen und keiner
weiß so richtig gut gemacht wenn ich
eine sache verbessern würde ich hätte
versucht den rap noch krasser zu wollen
also wo ich einmal in sich drin so dass
wir noch kompakter ist aber sonst alles
gut leute ich zeig euch jetzt aber noch
mal schnell wie ich den belegen würde
das war bei dir professionell aus meint
dann nehme ich mir hier ein bisschen
hiervon allerdings nicht zu viel weil
ich finde immer wenn zu viel fleisch
raub ist auch nicht geil vielleicht
schon da nehmen wir ein bisschen salat
und dann noch käse ich mir ein bisschen
mehr sein das fand ich bei marie gut
weil sie den käse mit unten im ofen
gepackt hat damit er so ein bisschen
schmerzt ist habe ich hier natürlich ich
habe mit und drüber
hat keiner gesehen okay du kannst es
einmal besser
der weg zum mitnehmen bitte
wirklich lecker tja leute wir hatten
jetzt zwei unterschiedliche rezepte
einmal von marie die vegetarische
edition mit ein paar änderungen aber
trotzdem hat das gut gemacht ich hatte
ja das große privileg ich durfte hin und
wieder aufs rezept spielen so sieht das
aus hier leute so bekommt man das
geliefert da sind dann halt das ist zum
beispiel das für den seelachs burger
also super easy schnell gemacht dann
würde ich auch sagen sagt auf jeden fall
den gutscheincode ab leute da gibt es
super viele rezepte darüber dass sie
ohne sie würde ich mal das
auszuprobieren werden jetzt wird abend
auch noch vielleicht den seelachs mahl
zubereitet und da an leckeren burger
machen danke fürs zuschauen wir sehen
uns haut rein leute